[Applaudissements]
cet écran via la caméra donc c'est vrai
que je donne l'impression aux gens de
les regarder mais en fait ce que je vois
l'image
ah ouais ça loi qui perdure moi je
comprends rien empêcher un but s'est
inversée non alors c'est le miroir qui
est inversée c'est pas la météo
attractive un gros mandat de merde et
bien voilà qui doit nous pousser c'est
la première fois c'est formidable de
dire ça qu'est bon pc sur la gueule
alors fermez les yeux fermés les yeux
[Rires]
alors on a eu des prisonniers la météo
catherine quoi je passe ou pis non mais
c'est pas vous voulez on peut servir une
soupe à quatre étoiles à bercy une soupe
puis on va la mettre au lit gentiment
demie commence à brest une salle eu à
vivre avec un astéroïde ans dans une
drôle de situation
je me précipite vers mon nom mais je
reste dans ses bras jusqu'à la fin non
c'est beau